hello super excited about this unboxing
because today I'm finally one-box
something that I've had for a few weeks
and I haven't had a chance to open it
sozin's Apple has failed to release any
sort of update from their monitors we
had to we had a resort to something else
so a lot of you guys suggested a bunch
of different 4k monitors and apparently
LG must have seen my cry and said hey we
just released this it was a little bit
ago at this point and they said hey we
want to send this to you I want to see
if you like it so I don't know if I like
it yet but it looks pretty off it's also
silver so it'll match my my office
doesn't say which way should I put it oh
it does actually it says open here and
it says do not stomp on pardon me
there's a lot of items in here I'm up
against this ball because I don't have
enough room here to move it forward
power bread bag of course base it's all
about that bass bout that bass no smells
like some fresh fresh tech oh this is
yeah we'll find out
leave the dogs nowhere near me look at
you I haven't even seen you yet but I
know you're gonna be good
stand that you mount the monitor to
which will mount each of the base look
at all these things so many cords
holy-moly USB C HDMI USB C a USBC to
another USB C oh this little little
number here never cut towards yourself I
say it as I do it clearly don't take
your own advice
baby this is what we came for baby real
thin so just shove this in here yep
shove it in oh man oh why did I do this
first you don't even need a screwdriver
guys they're just little turn thingies
you just turn them it's basically
foolproof
look at that you just turn them how do I
make this go up and down just like that
you just pull it up pull it down should
we go set it up I think we should
[Music]
let's turn her on and see what she looks
like how do I join it on that's cool
I'll figure it out there it is the
button
my dog is crazy to be 4k deep color deep
change settings I don't of ok I just
want your pewter to work that's all this
looks great I mean it doesn't even look
that cool in my camera but like I
promise like in real life it looks
pretty awesome real fresh real clean
[Music]
or guys well that's pretty much it I
have it all set up I'm not really sure
how I feel about it yet because I
haven't got a chance to really try it
out but so far everything looks really
awesome and really crisp and I'm glad to
finally have just one monitor instead of
having to I can switch back and forth
between my Mac and my PC hopefully in
the description if you guys want to see
all the specs and more information about
this monitor one of these days I will do
a full office tour but every time I go
to I'm like it's not done that's see you
guys later
happy tech Tuesday face I've got all the
necessary ingredients readily available
accessible here if Jenna wants to make a
cake she can make a cake if mat let's
make a cake he can make a cake if
anybody wants to make a cake you can
make a cake